يكشف ان ملك بريطانيا تشارز الثالث سيرتدي
ثيابا مخمليه من الحريق القرمزي
والارجواني في حفل تتويجه يوم السادس من
مايو القصر كشف ان هذه الثيابه تتهجده
الملك جورج السادس اثناء تتويجه عام
1937 مجموعه الثياب التي سيرتديها الملك
تشارلز وزوجته كاملا كانت محفوظه سابقا او
مصنوعه لدى شركه حياكه الملابس القديمه في
لندن منذ 300
عاما وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه قالت ان الف
الجنود والبحاره والطيارين سيرافقون
الملكه بين قصر باكينغهام وكنسه في طريقه
خلال مراسم التتويج صحف بريطانيا قالت انه
تمت دعوه ملوك ومجموعه من كبار شخصيات من
جميع انحاء العالم الى مراسم التتويج فيما
رجحت ان هذا التطوير سيكون اقل حجما من
تتويج الملكه اليزابيث الذي كلف حوالي 22
مليون دولار